RIGHT UP TO THE FRONT LINES IN
THE SOUTH AS UKRAINE VOWS TO
CHASE RUSSIANS BACK OVER THE
BORDER.
>> A LIGHTNING ADVANCE BY
UKRAINE AGAINST RUSSIA LEAVES A
WINDED LANDSCAPE ALMOST EMPTIED
OF PEOPLE.
UKRAINE CLAIMS TO HAVE BROKEN
THROUGH RUSSIAN FRONT LINES
CLOSE TO HERE, CAPTURING SEVERAL
VILLAGES IN A NEW
COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
WE HAVE BEEN STOPPED AT A ROAD
BLOCK ABOUT A KILOMETER SHORT OF
WHERE THEY SAY THERE HAVE BEEN
INCOMING FIRE IN THE LAST 24
HOURS.
BUT WE CAN SEE VERY CLEARLY HERE
THAT IN THESE TREE LINES, THESE
TREE LINES WERE ALL OCCUPIED BY
UKRAINIAN FORCES UNTIL 24 HOURS
AGO AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
COURT OFFENSIVE.
THIS IS CLEARLY BEEN A LOCATION
WHERE THERE'S BEEN PRETTY HEAVY
FIGHTING.
THE FIGHTING IS NOW
CONCENTRATED, WE UNDERSTAND FROM
SOLDIERS WE HAVE SPOKEN TO HERE,
CLOSE TO THE FRONT LINE.
FIVE OR SIX KILOMETERS BEYOND
AND BEYOND THAT LIES THE
ULTIMATE GOAL OF KHERSON.
THE REGIONAL CAPITAL CAPTURED BY
RUSSIA IN MARCH WAS ROCKED BY
FIGHTING, RUSSIA SAID TODAY.
ITS FORCES CLAIM TO HAVE WIPED
OUT A UKRAINIAN PARTISAN CELL IN
A FIREFIGHT.
WHO WON THE SKIRMISH IS UNCLEAR,
BUT THE CITY HAS BEEN THE CENTER
OF UKRAINIAN RESISTANCE FOR
MONTHS.
UKRAINE SAYS THAT IT HAS DAMAGED
THE BRIDGES CONNECTING IT TO THE
RUSSIAN HELD LEFT BANK OF THE
DNIPRO RIVER, CUTTING OFF KEY
SUPPLY LINES FOR THE RUSSIANS.
>> Translator: CONTINUE TO TRY
TO SET UP A FERRY CROSSING, BUT
THE WHOLE AREA WHERE IT CAN BE
DEPLOYED IS ALSO UNDER OUR FIRE
CONTROL AND WILL BE HIT.
>> RUSSIA'S CLAIM TO HAVE HELD
OFF AN OFFENSIVE IN WHICH IT
LOST AT LEAST FOUR VILLAGES IN
48 HOURS, ACCORDING TO UKRAINIAN
MILITARY SOURCES.
MARIA AND HER HUSBAND STAYED ON
HER FARM IN UKRAINE'S FRONT LINE
THROUGHOUT THE WAR TO FEED THEIR
LIVESTOCK.
THE MONTHS OF SHELLING HAVE LEFT
HER SHAKEN.
THIS WEEK, SHE'S ENDURED JETS
STREAMING OVERHEAD AS UKRAINIAN
FIGHTERS ATTACKED RUSSIAN
TARGETS.
>> Translator: I HID INSIDE THE
HOUSE.
MY HEART WAS JUMPING OUT EVERY
TIME.
I WAS SCREAMING SO LOUD WHEN THE
PLANES WERE FLYING OVER.
I WAS SO SCARED.
GOD SAVE US.
>> F